creo que la representación es enorme porque
cuanto más se pueden ver en
diferentes medios, más no se
sienten aislados, ya sabes,
más sienten que pueden participar
en el mundo en el que están
[Música]
jason reynolds
[  Música]
sentí el zumbido eléctrico,
incluí temas muy parecidos a nichos como cuando
llegas a casa después de la oración de la mezquita
cuando suena como música rap
desde el auto, sabes algo como
un poco tonto y entretenido
que sabes que alguien podría relacionarse
y  di oh me gusta ese
personaje quiero escribir
algo así quiero ser
así o estoy feliz de verme
representado así
[Música]
es
definitivamente vimos un aumento de libros
libros negros que se vendían cuando George Floyd
fue asesinado y nuestro público objetivo,
que siempre ha sido afroamericano
y gente de toda la
diáspora africana, ellos eran nuestro cliente objetivo,
siempre fueron los que
nos apoyaron y compraron libros, pero luego
esa red se amplió cuando George Floyd  fue
asesinado y entonces tenemos todo tipo de
fondos que vienen
[Música]
[Aplausos] [
Música]
[Aplausos]
[Música]
tú